like how if you were gonna put the money
you've made from music that you've
created
compared to like the personal appearance
you know from the shows like how would
that like uh
yeah what's the pie chart
I'd say live shows
I'm gonna be very very kind of broad
sure it I I I'm assuming it's like
probably over 80 percent there you go of
my income maybe more
and um and then I do a lot of
endorsement deals
which is also quite high too sure so the
like the music making my royalties for
my music is actually a very small
percentage that four billion streams on
Spotify didn't pay [__] well think about
this so I think for every million
streams it's 400 bucks wow that's even
worse than YouTube yeah so to go to one
billion it's 404 million right
[Applause]
yeah CPM is uh cost per Millennia which
is one thousand that's four I think it's
four million you get four million
dollars for one billion streams
four million dollars is not going
straight to you
it's split up with whoever owns the
master yeah and then once it gets to the
to my side I have to pay my managers
sure I have to pay my business managers
I have to pay lawyers yeah I have to pay
all these people and I have a team yeah
you know you subsidize all those
different costs I pay you make
you know twenty percent thirty percent
of of the hundred you know so the
reality and then the taxes on top of
that yeah for sure so it's like it's it
sounds like a lot of money but then when
you just dice it up you realize you're
only getting the the tail of the fish I
I only just started really paying
attention to accounting and um I I
shouldn't say this but I'll go ahead and
I will but there was a period of uh of
time that we were looking at where uh
the accountants told me that I generated
1.1 million dollars in Revenue but I
netted
97 000.
I'm not surprised yeah I'm not surprised
at all it's it's gnarly it's really not
after tax no why don't they I don't know
after tax you got you you got maybe 50
Grand yeah I mean it's after taxes
okay that would be crazy 1.1 million 50
Grand I know but now attention to be
fair we we found uh um an inventory
discrepancy which did add like like
another 100 so it was more like 1.1
million to 200 right but then again
that's and that was a in a year
[Music]
I could buy this I could buy that I
could buy this and then and then the
reality is you have you have 100 grand
right it's scary it's 100 so maybe you
spend like 20 grand
20 grand tops right like that's your
that's your safety spend not not like
400 Grand yeah or 300 Grand whatever it
is you know like it's it's it's it's
insane it's absolutely insane like uh
how it all just vanishes this is why I
still fly Spirit do you I flew Spirit on
the spirit like I don't mind it that's
fantastic I mean I fly spirit I Fly
Southwest I fly uh
you know all these other airlines every
uh every airline that can get me well
you know Direct
I literally was stuck on the tarmac
because like there was like yelling and
crying and screaming going on like you
know and they wouldn't leave the plane
but
um that's really cool man can you
imagine you're in Spirit Airlines and
it's sitting next to Steve Aoki well if
you're sitting next to me you like I'm
like it's impossible to talk to me
because I have noise cancellation
headphones on I got this huge like eye
mask and then I have a big pillow that
I'm already laying against and then I'm
just got a sweater that's like kind of
like a hooded over to everything else so
like good luck getting any more
attention I'm just out I'm not cold that
yeah that's crazy we might want to
rethink our uh our air travel
was it uh yeah we we spent a a boatload
of money on air travel last year I still
went everywhere on the tour bus it makes
no sense it's crazy do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude